How did you start?
How did you start with the idea of,
you know, I want to farm? Yes?
But then I also want to teach
because those are two different things.
I think the first recognizing
the huge problem
that we have in Puerto Rico
There are economic powers also.
They don't want us to produce more
because if we grow more,
we are going to buy less.
How is it
that one of the most fertile regions
in the world
is in providing for its people?
Thanks to an American law,
the “Jones Act” Most goods entering
Puerto Rico must make a pitstop in Florida
and arrive
on American made, owned and operated
ships.
The result?
Grocery prices in Puerto
Rico are 25% higher than on the mainland.
And making matters
worse, products leaving Puerto Rico
are also bound by the Jones Act,
inflating prices of their exports,
making them simply too expensive to
compete with those from other countries.
So what's left?
High prices and little investment
in agriculture.
It's absurd.
Farmers like Ian know this
and are taking
matters into their own hands.